I guess this week is a former
professional wrestler movie star
television host author and oh yeah
former governor of Minnesota governor
Jesse Ventura welcome to the Rubin
report great to be on the Rubin report
it's far too long since we talked to
each other it's been a while now first
off you view we've done this a couple of
times as I've bounced around from
networks and you've bounced around but
first off are you off the grid right
this moment no I'm right this moment in
the heart of Manhattan so that's hardly
off the grid no I'm in the middle of a
book tour and I had to fly to New York
and I'll spend four days out here doing
the the massive publicity stuff that you
do with every book and then I'll go back
to Minnesota and then I've just signed a
new contract with Russian television
America so I'll be getting ready to do
32 shows for them we'll crank out eight
of them and then I'll go to Mexico and
then at some point I'll do eight more
and we haven't figured out exactly when
where and how yet but it won't be off
the grid because now that I work for
Russia they don't have the political
pull and the paperwork to do the show
for Mexico so it can't be off the grid
any more I'll be doing it from Minnesota
which of course is on the grid right now
what kind of red-blooded American that I
know you are could work from Russia well
that's a question I'm gonna ask in my
first show I want to know what Russia's
done now to make us hate them so bad I
mean they were our allies in World War
two they fought side by side with us in
fact they took the brunt of World War
two against the Nazis and yet before the
war was even over there our enemy while
I realized why finally I read a book on
Allen Dulles if you know who he was
former head of the CIA yeah well think
about in a minute
Wall Street ran our country back then
what is Wall Street's biggest fear
socialism
well they would Wall Street would rather
get in with fascists and Nazis than they
would socialists and that's how I
determined why before the war was even
over almost Allies to my father were now
our enemy and so I want to know now that
they're not socialists anymore I was
there in December they are full-blown
capitalists in fact they've embraced
capitalism so strongly in Moscow stores
every stores open 24 hours a day Wow now
that's embracing competition and
capitalism so now that they're
capitalists why do we still want a war
with them wait as a joke I said wait a
minute because they're capitalists and
they're even white so they've got
everything going for them they got
everything going for them you know and
and I and I would like an answer as to
why we continue to build up to another
Cold War the only answer I can come up
with is feeding the industrial war
complex yeah isn't that ultimately what
so many of our decisions ultimately come
down to that there's just so much money
out there that we always need a new
enemy and not to say look Putin's doing
some strange stuff in Ukraine obviously
in some other places but that we're
always looking for another enemy just
because that is the money machine yeah
it we we are now a culture of war I mean
take a look on TV you see Arnold
Schwarzenegger doing those commercials
for the video game right we glorify war
we've decided that people that go to war
our heroes and need to be glorified well
for my first question is how is killing
someone else a hero and and it brings up
a great point that I did on off-the-grid
I raised the question who's more
powerful God or government well clearly
government is because God says thou
shalt not kill there's no asterisk there
it's simple thou shalt not kill right
yes yet if you kill for
government's behalf or at the behest of
government not only can you kill you're
a hero if you do it if you kill for
government you're a hero well that
clearly says government doesn't listen
to God and God doesn't penalize
government for it
so government's clearly more powerful
than God yeah and it seems that God has
a bunch of believers who are all mixed
up because a lot of people are killing
in the name of God too even if he says
don't do it exactly same for good point
same thing but yet you're made a hero if
you kill at behest of government shoot
they got holidays for you they'll pay
the National Football League to honor
you that's that one yeah that swept
under the rug quick when they found out
in the defense bill our tax dollars were
paying the billionaire owners of the NFL
to honor the veterans what do you make
of that what's going on now with
Kaepernick and this instant you know
kneeling for the national first of all
that's a slap in the face to me as a
veteran mm-hmm that these billionaire
football owners have to get paid to
honor me now Kaepernick I support him a
hundred percent you don't have to agree
with what he's protesting if you do or
don't but you need to support his right
to do it because if we take away Colin
Kaepernick's right to not stand for the
flag one thing people need to remember
clearly you can't mandate patriotism
you can't force patriotism the last
people who force patriotism was 1930s
Germany they were called Nazis that was
forced patriotism patriotism has earned
a government earns your patriotism a
government can't mandate or make you be
patriotic they have to earn it and Colin
Kaepernick whether you agree with what
he's doing or not should be supported in
his right to protest that's what makes
our country great well you saw the
second time he did it who was standing
next to him that green beret that wrote
an op-ed piece
in his favor stating he didn't agree
with him but he supported his right to
do it and that's what he defended our
country to have that right and all you
noticed the people who protests the most
are the ones that were never in the
military right does that mad in you when
you see that people simply don't
understand the two-way street that
freedom really is because he has the
freedom to do it in that he doesn't have
to stand for it and then other people
have the freedom to mock him so no one's
saying they don't have the freedom to
Malcolm but that people don't understand
that sort of social contract that we
have well it was like when I was
governor I tried to tell people look
with freedom comes to the freedom to be
stupid
it's a yin and a yang that if you're
going to accept freedom humans are gonna
make stupid decisions you have to accept
that as part of freedom that the freedom
and like I told my people you can't
legislate stupidity you can't make every
time a person does something stupid you
can't make it against the law right like
to me the most asinine law in America
it's against the law to commit suicide
well if the person successful how do you
prosecute up right and if he's not
you're gonna put him in jail because he
tried to kill himself yeah that leads to
my book marijuana manifesto how how can
you put people in jail for committing a
crime against themselves now it might be
stupid to use drugs maybe maybe not
depending on who you are but are you
you're making it against the law and
putting you in prison cuz you commit a
crime against yourself in a free society
yeah so in this regard would you say
that you're fully libertarian cuz that
strikes me as a very libertarian view
you're saying we're saying you do what
you want with your own body big whoop
and do what you want in life as long as
you don't harm anyone else you do what
you're free to do as long as you don't
harm another person or force them to do
something that's not free will for them
damn as far as doing drugs hey read my
book for a hundred and sixty years
marijuana was the economic drive to the
entire United States of America did you
know that the British would take
marijuana in lieu of money huh I did not
know that yes because they needed it for
sales so they could colonize sales on
their ships rope all of that while
England was only the size of New York
State
they couldn't have the room to grow it
so they made the colonists grow it so
that they could take it and use it to
further their Armada and their big fleet
I cover it all in the book first so for
a hundred and sixty years marijuana was
the economic engine that drove the
United States economy it wasn't cotton
until they invented the cotton gin
because marijuana was easier to harvest
yeah so what do you make of the way that
the feds and Obama particularly has
dealt with marijuana because we know
that in a lot of states now it's
medicinal illegal we've got a couple of
recreational Eagle I'm here in
California I have a license for it and I
don't even smoke that often but I
thought if I'm gonna do it let me let me
go ahead and get the license but but
Obama and the feds have come in and they
closed medicinal dispensaries here you
know they're they're legal by the state
yeah well they want people to suffer
I'll tell you what made me so passionate
on this I won't say who because I
respect people's privacy of health but
someone very close to me marijuana has
given me back my standard of living Wow
that's how powerful because someone
close to me developed an epileptic
seizure condition at a later age and was
seizing four times a week and I was
there I had to deal with this seizure
well the person was put on for
pharmaceutical drugs one at a time none
of them worked
they all had horrible side effects and
the seizures continued the person then
went to Colorado at the time where
medical was legal obtained it
the seizures immediately stopped now
they can the person could get it in
Minnesota because it's legal there now
and for two years now this person has
not had a seizure yeah and has
completely weaned off the
pharmaceuticals completely so it's the
marijuana that is stopping the epileptic
seizures so to Barack Obama and all our
government how dare you make people
suffer because of your shortsightedness
and money because it all comes back to
money if they legalize that they want
Big Pharma to run it so the big
corporation will reap the profits yeah
they don't want it to where poor people
can grow it in their backyard and be
able to use it like when I grew up in
south Minneapolis every summer my mom
had a tomato patch we didn't have a big
yard when a inner-city yet she would
have enough Tomatoes we need fresh
tomatoes all summer when they came well
you can do the same thing with marijuana
which means poor people don't have to
pay the system to get it and use it
there's the rub you know the irony here
of course is that all of these
prescription drugs that everybody's
taking all you have to do is watch any
of the commercials the commercials half
of the commercials telling you about the
side effects and then with the ultimate
irony it's usually marijuana that will
deal with those side effects so what do
we do so do we need basically like
Starbucks to come in and say we're gonna
start corporate izing marijuana no no
you don't want corporations taking
control well in terms of the angle part
okay look at it this way mm-hmm I don't
like Budweiser beer I would rather have
some micro brew or some brew that's
handmade Minnesota and doesn't sit in a
can on a shelf for months before I buy
it in the liquor store well that's what
you can do if you eliminate the
corporation's from marijuana then you'll
have local it'll be locally grown it'll
be local everything and that's why in
Ohio it failed because they had picked
out only two corporate
nations that would control the whole
thing and the marijuana smokers said
[ __ ] that's bullcrap we want it to
where anybody can grow it anyone can use
it we want it free like the plant is the
plant grows wild it was here before we
got here and ran off the Indians or the
Native Americans it was growing here so
why shouldn't it be able to grow wild
and you be able to harvest it without
having to pay the government to do it
yeah I'm with you so where do you stand
on legalization in general obviously
you're you're fully for legalizing
marijuana but that always then it
hearkens the next question well which is
well does he want to legalize cocaine
and heroin and everything else down the
road yeah yes here's why addiction is a
medical problem addictions of disease
you can be addicted to food all right
tomorrow morning let's imagine go to a
hypothetical let's say tomorrow morning
we could magically make Starbucks and
all caffeine coffee disappear what do
you think would happen to society
tomorrow morning if all these addicts
and I use the term addicts because they
are addicted and people need to
understand that if you have to have
coffee in the morning how dare you talk
about any other drug yeah I mean my head
my head would literally explode in the
morning I can't lie at luncheon see yeah
I've had two sips in my life and spit it
out both times to me it tastes like crap
really and so I don't drink coffee and
I'm hyper enough I don't need caffeine
to get going well the point I'm making
is everybody's addicted to something
obesity is a huge problem in our country
because the people are addicted to
eating now if they push themselves away
from the table and exercise you won't be
obese right eat the right foods but do
we limit them no and like when they make
it legal it's not really legal even in
Colorado let me give you the example I
could drive to Colorado tomorrow right
and I could pull a semi
in and I could fill that semi up with
tobacco couldn't I
sure I could buy as many cigarettes as I
wanted and fill the semi up I could
drive to five liquor stores and I could
buy all their booze and fill the semi up
and nobody questioned me as long as my
credit card could pay for it right I
could buy as much yet
marijuana a Colorado resident can only
buy one ounce at a time and and if
you're not from Colorado you can only
get a half an ounce that ain't freedom
yeah that means it's still highly
restricted so when they talk about it's
legal now no it isn't really because
they still limit how much you can buy
and that why should the government have
any say-so whatsoever in how you spend
your money or if you want to buy o45
outboard motor engines even though you
don't have a boat right you know you
want to do that you have the freedom to
do that well that's freedom right
meanwhile if you buy a pressure cooker
you're on a CIA watch list or something
maybe yeah who knows yeah but uh yeah
and so it still isn't free because it's
so heavily restricted right now and for
what for what now do you know who did it
William Randolph Hearst really the big
guy with the newspapers died in the
thirties I drove that by his uh that
castle a couple months ago here's why
he owned 26 newspapers and marijuana and
hemp make better paper than wood he
owned thousands of acres of timberland
so he bought off the Republicans and
Democrats got them to make marijuana
federally illegal so it forced us to buy
his timber to make pay pan when you
start linking this stuff together it's
as he said earlier it's it's all down to
models our money so so one more thing on
marijuana and then let's talk about
those Democrats and Republicans because
I have a feeling you have a couple
things to say about them as well it is
the most fascinating part about
marijuana that it's almost the reverse
of every other vice so for example with
booze if you drink we know you build a
resistance to it you need more
drink if you do smoke crack or snort
coke or drink coffee you always need
more marijuana I find that I can firmly
say this for me I used to smoke a lot of
marijuana now I could maybe take one
puff and I'm good for hours and I do
that maybe once a week so it actually
has like a built in regulation system to
it to actually maybe but what you may be
facing is this it's more powerful today
than what it was years ago because of
the strains and the way they're able to
grow it right now that's not bad and let
me explain it's more healthy for you to
be able to take one puff than having to
smoke the whole joint sure see it's the
same as booze okay
you can go out and buy a liqueur that's
maybe 20% or you can go buy 151 rum well
which one's gonna knock you into
tomorrow quicker 151 rum is gone okay so
that's content well in the case of
marijuana if it's more potent
you're never gonna die from it the great
thing about marijuana you can't OD it
nobody's died we're not gonna die from
it you can't you can die from overdosing
alcohol easily and all he said but
marijuana you can't and if it's more
powerful it means you smoke less you
might be able to have one joint if
you're a prolific smoker who smokes all
day one joint may last you the whole day
yeah I'm take once in the morning one at
lunch one in the evening and one before
bed yeah when I got my license I went to
the dispensary and I was looking around
you know they got it in chocolate and in
you know in water and edible every every
which way and vaping and all that stuff
and I looked at the guy and I was like
do you have any weed in weed form
cuz I just wanted like old school weed
he looked at me like I was a little
weird but they eventually had it for me
nah he really did he was probably doing
that just ink because this other stuff
might be more expensive again follow the
money it is utterly foolish now we've
spent since the war on drugs started in
1972 by Nicks and we've spent close to
it
trillion dollars fighting it putting
campbell in jail for doing something
recreationally for themselves yeah and
they're not harming anyone
like my fate my famous quote marijuana
is to rock and roll what beer is to
baseball imagine if you went to the
ballgame and you couldn't have a hotdog
in a beer well when you go to a rock
concert in the 60s and 70s when I grew
up you didn't have to have pot you just
went there
peopled light a joint and send it down
the aisle people would not be happy we
would ever I wanted to be happy at all
yeah and yet they won't let you smoke
pot at a rock concert it's ridiculous I
went to a journey concert in Orange
County about a year ago and I got narked
while my friend and I were puffing on a
little a little joint I mean can you
believe that outdoor concert by the way
[Music]
you
[Music]